اللقاحات لعلاج السرطان هو حلم يطارده
العلماء لعقود من الزمن قريبا قد يصبح
حقيقه ولقاحات ام ار ان اي يمكن انتاجها
في اقل من ثمانيه اسابيع
يعمل على تحفيز الجهاز المناعي على مهاجمه
نوع معين من الخلايا السرطانيه في اورام
المريض مع ترك الانسجه السليمه دون
مهاجمتها التقنيه الحديثه هي نفس الفكره
التي استخدمتها بعض الشركات في انتاج
لقاحات كوفيد وتستخدم مفهوم الطب الشخصي
بمعنى ان كل مريض يعالج وفق جناته بخلاف
نهج العلاج الموحد كلعلاج الكيماوي تؤخذ
عينه من ورم المريض ويتم تحديد الطفرات
غير الموجوده في الخلايا السليمه وبمساعده
الذكاء الاصطناعي يتم تصنيع لقاحات تستهدف
تلك الطفرات المسؤوله عن نمو السرطان اما
الاقراص التي يتم تناولها بالفم فتعمل على
وقف نشاط انزيم مسؤول عن تطور بعض انواع
السرطانات التي يصعب علاجها وبحسب اسرتك
تم استخدام الدواء من قبل ما يقرب من 700
الف مريض في جميع انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات